in the last year not just loads of
streams well your little baby bear baby
bear is now he's one he was just born
the last time we were here yeah I mean
it was a bit sad I had a job that
somebody booked in by accident on his
birthday which I was like this is
terrible I got the news I was like oh my
god this sad is that my chips are cooked
right here no I actually made his
birthday better in the end because we
had the whole first day she'd arranged a
whole party was all bear themed we paid
around like cars I was sat at the kids
table obviously been you know it's
younger we were eating sushi and posh
stuff and I was I he's got fish fingers
and so we had a great time in and in the
morning all my family was over so he got
like a whole thing of birthdays before I
went which was fantastic is something
I'll never forget and you know I hope
you had the best time he's his first
time on a rocking horse and he was
absolutely buzzing some more that's my
sir
and it's so sweet of course because he
won't remember any of it
[Music]